[Music]
I made it in time uh glad to see what
this I just broke my pen glad to be with
you today a lot of developments since
yesterday obviously the Nashville
Manifesto which is available now
publicly we made some predictions
yesterday and uh surprisingly they all
came true
but there's quite a bit more to that um
if you didn't understand that the media
in big Tech is the enemy of a free
people well hold on to your butts I
think today we'll eliminate any doubt
let's get on with
it but what's that looks like a hatch
should we open
it I think we have to it looks
old
listen you smell something I can't see a
thing it's too dark
hello well hello boys is it all clear
out there clear what how long have you
been down there since y 2K did the
computers destroy the world
no not the way you think yeah it's a
long story wait how have you been
surviving down there since before 2000
kid beans and pickles pick how have you
survived 20 plus years on pickles
pickles was my German
Shepherd God
gross just is there anything you need
that we can maybe help you with a fresh
bucket of
yeah we don't have did she say did
did she say bucket like a bucket to sh
in or she be like a bucket of
there's no way do you say do you say
like a a a bucket to sh no you want a
fresh bucket of yes I don't I don't
think we should help this lady I don't I
don't feel good about it forg you she's
eating her dog she's also eating you
don't know that well she could be doing
other things with what she be it's not a
bucket she she corrected me and said
it's a bucket of maybe she's building
another she's not turning what building
she's not building stairs look we can't
get you a bucket of but I think I can do
you one better how about a 3mon supply
emergency food kit from Patriot Supply
they're the leading brand in emergency
food supplies and if you go to prep
withth crow.com like on a computer
yeah come back when you got a fresh
bucket of
sh go to Prep withth crow.com Prep
withth crow.com
it is prep withth crow.com I'm supposed
to say it three times I think the media
is not going to give anyone a fair shape
you will see it on display they are
scared when you look at the recent polls
they have nothing to offer these are
empty suits I'm Stuart VY and I am
thrilled to be sitting along saw Ilia
C
Univision 52 points that's the lead
Donald Trump has on you tons of fun you
look at him the wax museum K's the
hair put on a dress does anyone
actually think that Chris Christie had a
good night world star see I'm trying to
be nice Don't Call Him a fat pig doesn't
matter if you're George W bush Ronda
Sanchez Whoever has an R next to their
name is going to get the Trump treatment
the media is is not your friend it is
the modern version
[Music]
[Applause]
proa
know change
[Music]
it was a little longer because I need a
little uh pep in my step we have uh
we're running on very little sleep here
y very little sleep here uh at the show
uh appreciate you being with us I know
that there are a lot of you with us uh
really quickly let's just get to the
rundown what we'll be covering today we
will be discussing the natural Manu to
release the aftermath of course we've
been suppressed and outright removed
from Big tech there was a spokesperson
who claims to speak on behalf of all of
the parents who attacked us as well as
our source trying to intimidate
investigative journalists as well as
whistleblowers and even the Nashville
mayor decided to get in in uh in line
with his weird little balloon
head so this is a little strange let me
ask you this right off the bat what
shocks you most now that the dust has
settled a little bit and then it's been
kicked back up as it relates to the
Nashville man Manifesto the writings uh
and has anything surprised you most as
it relates to um the sort of falling out
I guess and we just had some
developments this morning that's why we
started a little late from The New York
Times all the News That's fit to
so we'll get into that and more
uh boy hey you know what happy to be
here I'm glad to be here if this means
that YouTube suspends us Facebook gets
rid of us New York Times wants to come
after us the
mayor we're fine I mean we're not fine
you know it's going to be very hard and
expensive but we're glad to do it for
you number two c Morgan how are you sir
I'm doing well and hey by the way the
the do it for you audience out there
thank you so much mug Club you probably
experienced a little blip at the
beginning there don't worry about it
there's so many new people that signed
up and so many of you that are watching
right now it's pretty big numbers for
for mug club that streng servers every
day we're going to be strengthening
those today there are a lot of you today
so it was a little bit laggy crashed
those watching exclusively on mug Club I
know if you're in the chat let us know
if it's working for you it's it's a good
thing but we are going to ensure that uh
you know we probably have to I don't
know how many more Millions to spend on
service but it's a good problem to have
uh when you hear this you know who's in
third
chair you love him most of
you most of you no 9th November 9th days
I have off days at 11th he'll be at good
nights don't call it Charlie at Raleigh
North Carolina and you can see the rest
of his dates uh at brian.com and he has
a show here on mug Club on Tuesdays off
limits Mr Brian Ken how are you I'm well
my friend good to be on the outside with
you looking in at all the hypocrisy so
let's go and craziness how long did you
rehearse that in the mirror I didn't I
thought to myself I well I got this you
told me to change my you know you didn't
like that yeah because you a name brand
sweater they'll sue us so cozy though
but then I then I changed it for cashmir
it is it's cashmir oh boy I don't even
know what it is I just know silk comes
from worms so I don't like it Okay so
yesterday just a recap for those of you
who missed it you can go to ler.com
[Music]
be this the this YouTube dump
button that means head on over to rumble
that's a signal to Mission Control you
absolutely should have hit should you
should have already seen it should have
already hit it because we are not
removed from YouTube but YouTube is
using Rico against us because we're a
criminal organization so yeah I'm the
head of it we knew the story a Fredo at
least oh come on we knew that's an
insult to your people we knew that we
get uh some attention uh and we knew
that you would if you shared it so we
made predictions yesterday and this is
something that if you guys know my old
friend Andrew this is something that uh
he discussed uh you get to finish the
sentences of the left you know what
they're going to do before they do it I
didn't expect them to do it as quickly
or as dishonestly as they did and we
have some clips here today from some
interviews that were conducted that then
were released and chopped up but
yesterday on the show we said you know
what call us to the mat we are going to
make these predictions as to how the
coverage will play out you know what
let's call it like Gerald said the left
won't cover it or they'll try and get us
Bann behind the scenes that includes by
the way all of media and big Tech
uh I would predict that people some
people on the right will cover it don't
know how much attribution there will be
because a lot of people don't want to
highlight that they haven't covered it
themselves uh and you'll probably see
some blowback as to well you shouldn't
have covered this because you could
create copycats right that's some of the
virtue signaling that you will see and I
would love to hear from you comment
below if that's if that's a line of
thought to which you
subscribe and I that's how I'm call it
spoiler
alert I man we were right yeah yeah
there's no
Prestige it's so what happened the video
was removed from YouTube where they said
it us being a criminal organization uh
the manifesto was also been banned on
all major social media platforms with
the exception of X there were a couple
of warnings that went out were taken
down uh by X and of course uh not just
us but the manifesto itself was attacked
by local and National media repeatedly
uh the Covenant spokesperson who claims
to speak on behalf of all of the parents
uh has attacked us and demanded money I
guess and then the mayor of Nashville
himself launched an invest an
investigation but here's something that
you're not seeing okay no one after I
would say noon Central yesterday no one
is refuting the
authenticity it started with how do we
know this is authentic right from maybe
about half an hour to an hour then
people were jumping on the bandwagon
claiming that they had confirmed the
authenticity when they would have had no
way to do so and after that no one has
refuted the authenticity including the
mayor including the police department
they are attacking the messenger so why
would that be and I know that there's
some people who are new here now there
are some people who will buy this this
live from this uh self-appointed spokes
person um that this is this is harming
anyone who was involved with the
shooting U not a lot of people are
actually buying that line but there are
a lot of people out there who who are
inquisitive saying yeah it makes sense
manifest the National Police Association
said that we have the right to do this
is you know based on prent look at all
the other manifestos why is the media so
aggressively trying to bury this and
that's the same reason that they're
attacking this program and all of you to
be clear for sharing this many of you
have lost your accounts for sharing it
so let me tell you why remember this is
the same group of people meaning the
media entertainment industrial complex
who uh handled it this way from the
beginning so right after the shooting
they were rather than focusing on
accurate reporting and making sure that
everyone was kept safe and understanding
the motives understanding the targets
they were tripping over pronouns the
shooter has been identified as
28-year-old female Audrey hail said
she's a former student of the school and
confirmed that audre hill was a
identified herself as a transgender
person tonight nearly a month after
metro police shot and killed the gunman
in that case where Monday a shooter
black blasted through locked doors using
a high powerered rifle there it looks
like they
pass some type of front entrance police
tonight on why they believe the as
salant may have had some weapons
training I want to go to aana Patton a
former classmate of the shooter she
received a direct message from the
shooter on Instagram student uh at the
school I don't know what grade she's
attended of grades but we do uh firmly
believe she was a student there there
was she there was they there was Aiden
there was
Audrey by the way we also have a collage
plenty of other mainstream Outlets they
were trying super hard to make sure they
got the pronouns right let's bring up
collage B2 look at CNN New York Times oh
yeah right there USA Today uh CNN here's
a quote police have referred to hail as
the quote female shooter when asked for
clarification a spokesperson told CNN
hail used male pronouns on a social
media profile the New York Times there
was confusion later on Monday about the
gender identity of the as salent in the
Nashville shooting the suspect appeared
to identify as a man in recent months
USA Today police on Monday afternoon
said that the shooter was a transgender
man officials had initially
misidentified the gender of the shooter
this is the point because you're going
to see today they want to distance
themselves from
[Music]
that
shameful it is disturbing and uh our
hearts go out to uh th those the trans
Community as they are under attack right
now Tennessee's already Under Siege
transgender Community is terrified one
Advocate told NBC news we are already
fearing for our lives now it's even
worse pronouns do not kill children
right people with guns kill children my
fear is that folks will continue to to
weaponize things against the trans
Community with this being one of them
transgender community and its supporters
see a disturbing Trend in anti-trans
legislation in States across the country
bathroom bans pronoun bans educational
restrictions on gender identity topics
right our human right trans right our
human rights every death is a tragedy
y'all seven
lives so if a
shooter uh happens to be white but isn't
a
[Music]
white
New York Times yesterday and it tells
you everything's going to play it says
hi there my name is Emily coochin I'm a
reporter with the New York Times I'm
working on a story on Mr cr's
publication of the Covenant writings and
just left the press conference where one
parent Brent Leatherwood was critical of
the decision to publish those photos he
described it as chasing clicks at one
point and said that the proceeds from
the video should go to the
families I mean you don't even wait to
say more money more money more money I
watched the video earlier this morning
and will'll incorporate some of that but
also wanted to make sure Mr Crowder
didn't have any additional comment or
response to the push back thank you now
here's the thing the article was
released today I I did respond to this
person you did I did they didn't include
my response oh this was theide that we
were chasing clicks and we should give
the revenue the proceeds should go to
the families and let me again read this
he described it as chasing clicks and
that the proceeds from the video should
go to the families they asked me for
comment I gave them a
comment and it was very and I was very
very clear and I was very I I was very
care with my words I said thank you for
reaching out I appreciate you wanting to
be evenhanded in your writing process in
attempting to familiarize myself with
your previous writing I attempted to
access more of your past articles but
couldn't make it past the pay
wall bring it up overlay C2 this is this
is they want to say that they're and
this is the thing it's it's the LI first
off right there it's the lies by
Omission yeah it's the not including the
statement why because it makes you look
silly Emily coochin and then
it's the hypocrisy of accusing you of
doing exactly what it is that they're
doing hey the New York Times has
subscribers they have up they're just
not doing investigative journalism
you're you're paying for an expensive
Midtown office is what you're paying for
yeah you're not actually getting the
journalism that you're paying for
certainly not the entertainment and
don't and all of us had
[Music]
questions
that's my Club you know there's a promo
code undercover or subscribe to the New
York Times you could we are at least
offering you an option it's okay for
them to do it they don't do
investigative journalism they suppress
stories they don't actually break any
new stories anymore and they don't even
include the comment that they received
last night there's no excuse Emily you
are lazy and you don't do your due
diligence please you mustn't be afraid
to stop perpetuating the original
stereotype of female reporters
love well don't be fooled like they
don't send you those emails because they
want to get more information that's not
they're not doing any journalism there
they're basically writing a hitpiece and
they want you to say something that they
can then use against you or take out of
context or use half of what you said to
make it look like they're right let's
apply this to Mr Leatherwood who by the
way was a parent I believe of someone or
children who went to Covenant who were
not shot from what I understand not not
thank God and you've never heard me say
anything other than I cannot even
imagine dealing with that kind of a
tragedy but I want to know this person
who issued a press conference are there
any other relatives to those victims who
got the New York Times treatment where
they said hey would you like to comment
and they said yeah yeah I'm a parent I'm
an uncle I'm a mom I'm a grandparent I'm
a brother I'm a sister I would like to
know why this happened and if my
relative or friend was targeted and
that's not included you would never know
you would never know that there was a
comment issued if I didn't tell you
right now and we're going to get to more
of that and we are releasing full videos
and transcripts today on X from some of
the wonderful beacons of Journalism that
we had to deal with yesterday so let me
go to these predictions from yesterday
some of these developments which look
some people would be scared all right
fine mayor you want to investigate FBI
go ahead tell me the crime that's
committed they we are assured that this
was a felony
good make it stick now let's go back to
these predictions that we made yesterday
and let's see if they came to fruition
and it's not hey aren't we impressive
it's the left is so unimpressive they
are so lazy predictable and predictable
that you can you can see this from a
mile off so the first prediction that we
made yesterday okay was that big Tech
would of course try to ban throttle
censor Shadow ban you know what let's
call it like Gerald said the left won't
cover it it'll try and get us banned
behind the scenes that includes by the
way all of media and big Tech and what
is the net result this is exactly what
happened YouTube removed our video
stating oh we wanted to let you know our
team reviewed your content and we think
it violates our violent criminal
organizations policy an organization you
are the mafia my friend we're part of g
bo the
underworld I love it God how dare you
violent C or maybe they mean maybe they
mean the
[Music]
sh was it that where Charlie hun does
the worst worst American accent ever hey
we're about to go pick up a shipment of
AK-47s yeah that's how a biker talks
they said we know you may not have
realized this was a violation of our
policies so we're not applying a strike
to your channel well that's kind of you
however we have removed your video from
YouTube so look YouTube okay now this
also goes to Google Google band sharing
of it so that's alphabet so now all of
Google all of YouTube where people go
for their video content this doesn't
exist that's a starting point yeah and
we we talked about the Google thing
during the show yesterday we brought it
up for you to see that it said things
are changing very quickly no they're not
yeah there is a release of information
that's the only thing happened Google
then they decided to to ban the sharing
of it all together uh you have Reddit by
the way Reddit actually would suspend
accounts that freaks me out a little bit
yeah for sharing it at all so meta this
is Facebook Instagram you know the the
messenger app ban sharing it entirely it
says your post goes against our
community standards on violence uh and
incitement so just to be clear right now
You' just added up wow YouTube alphabet
Google meta means Facebook Instagram
even in your your your messenger apps
messaging people Bang
suspended that that that that sliver the
[Music]
pie
a
[Music]
and see it's hard to understand the
rules because this content is just fine
we want to get right to that breaking
news an anti-muslim terror attack in New
Zealand the Prime Minister there is
calling it one of the nation's Darkest
Days A gunman attacked two mosques while
hundreds of Muslims were praying the man
who is claiming responsib and charged
with murder is an extreme right-wing
white supremacist a total of 13 people
were shot in what they're calling a
racially motivated attack in
Jacksonville Florida four people are
dead including the gunman after shooting
inside a Dollar General Store
authorities held a news conference just
a few moments ago saying the incident
was racially motivated and they quoted
directly from the manifesto and a lot of
those to be clear they want you to live
in darkness right and that's not a good
thing for anybody whether you're left
whether you're right living in complete
darkness with a lack of transparency
Darkness isn't good we we tried to AB
test we ran an experiment here in the
office and it didn't go
[Music]
well
Captain Morgan what do you got so uh all
of those clips just so you know were
from the day uh of the shooting day
after the shooting that we just showed
you so the media was doing their job and
getting the information out to the
public and that was not going to be a
problem for anybody it wasn't going to
create any issues but also the uh the
previous school shooting obviously
Uvaldi was one of the most hair raising
experiences we ever had to see happen
and unfold uh but the evaldi foundation
is actually calling for for a boycott of
this show after the release of the
manifesto why why would you be calling
for a boycott of a show that discusses
the motivations behind a mass shooter so
that we can then maybe prevent more mass
shootings I would think that having some
kind of security having some kind of an
understanding of where these people may
be coming from would be in everyone's
best interest especially people touched
by tragedy though it may be hard to
relive these situations are you are you
saying the same things to the media that
cover this story on an anniversary date
because next year when it gets to March
there's probably going to be a story in
the media the one-year anniversary of
and by way them to that same standard I
seem to remember the Uvalde police chief
saying that they were fine policemen who
did a great job on the outset until more
video came to light where they waited in
the hallways with children dying the
transparency is where we all agreed even
found Common Ground we need to better
equip our police force oh my God they're
running away from gunfire remember after
that we found out that some parents were
being tased who trying toak they were
trying to break in to save their own
kids remember that I'm sure Michigan
control can can bring that up where he
said oh you know they did a great job
and maybe some we'll see what we could
do better he did a horrible job yeah you
were covering your butt and so at this
point hey you know what could there have
been warnings were there warnings were
there people who expressed concern we're
chasing down some other leads too as it
relates to Covenant just to be clear
yeah what if it's what if it's
preventable if this was preventable and
what if knowing this makes these more
preventable in the future and this is
why we do what we do look if you want to
support it like we said if you don't
tune into The Daily Show Brian's show
Alex Jones's show Nick depalo's Daily
Show still none of this investigative
journalism exists if not for you lot
credit.com mugclub $10 off if you enter
the promo code undercover also if you
just want to watch for free download the
rumble app if this hasn't if this hasn't
showed shown you that YouTube hates you
then nothing just download the rumble
app it's the easiest thing to do on your
mobile phone you'll get notifications
when things get up they will not crumble
they will not falter they will not bend
the knee to Big Tech okay let's go to
another prediction here and the reason
we're doing this is is not just as an is
not as an Endzone dance it's so that you
can see this happening in real time see
us calling it and see it coming to
fruition and know that this is exactly
what will happen in your life if you try
and speak the truth that's the issue
this may happen in your local school
with the teachers union it may happen in
your local police department with your
police Union it may happen if you work
for a company that's valuing Dei it can
happen to any of you so watch this
happen in real time we can fight for you
so that you don't have to every single
day if we're not doing that we're just
stealing your dollar right like the New
York Times with a subscription so uh
another prediction we made the second
one we said you know what probably
what's going to happen not probably
definitely we'll get blowback for
covering it they'll attack them
messenger and you'll probably see some
blowback as to well you shouldn't have
covered this because you could create
copycats right that's some of the virtue
signaling that you will
see I me one
guess the spin cycle of course has been
massive and this is only after it was
under keep in mind over seven months
Dead Silence nothing you knew nothing
you had your suspicions but you heard
nothing then this went to the number one
Trend millions of people saw it they had
to respond did they respond with saying
this isn't true no they responded by
trying to spin it saying this hurts
people by the way um I don't know if you
know this words are violence silence is
violence I used I remember when violence
was violence but now violence isn't
violence if it's perpetrated against the
right people so the Nashville media the
local media and it's always cute because
some of these people think they actually
are
journalists uh they had meltdowns over
the coverage you can bring up this
collage there uh Matt we have a WS sm4
Nashville WS sm4 Nashville SM V4 says
talk show hosts criticized for releasing
Covenant School shooters writings our
job nonprofit calls for boycott after
leak of Covenant School shooters
writings who cares it's amazing to me I
just wonder if the New York Times or one
of these mainstream Legacy Media Outlets
got a hold of that Manifesto and they
released it which I think they would
have um and then then I would have lik
to have seen that blowback it'd be very
interesting if there was any blowback at
all well this next who I spoke with from
WSM 4's uh I I guess he's their Chief
investigative
reporter is that is that his title yes I
want to make sure I don't get it wrong
because I can't tell by the eyeball test
Chief investigative reporter Chief
investigative reporter who honed the
chief meaning he never leaves the office
yes uh his name is Jeremy Finley and
look we're actually uploading this the
entire interview to X right now you can
bring this up as an overlay it is up on
X we will get it up on rumble on our
channels can you can you bring it up
just there as an overlay so people can
see go and follow me on Twitter the full
interview and it's full context boom
it's there because I want you to see
what
happens when you sit down and I knew
that this was going to be an interview
where um this guy had a little bit of an
axe to grind because this uh Outlet I
believe had tried to sue to get the
manifesto yeah they were part of it they
tried to and they didn't no uh so then
they were upset that somebody else did
and by the way the fact that no one
reached out to you locally means they
don't trust exactly yeah so I want you
to see how they cut the interview and
then we will show you some clips here
but again full transparency I want you
to go and watch the full interview also
because it's kind of
funny here's how WS sm4 Nashville's most
trusted news I have no idea if they are
they might be second most trusted news
but I'm sure they're trusted to some
degree here's how they cut the interview
and let it crowers admits he is biased
and believes he was right to release the
writings Crowder is no stranger to
controversy he's been accused of
homophobia misogyny and racism he has
remained defiant in the wake of these
criticisms and steadfast in his beliefs
including that it's taken too long for
metrop police to release the Covenant
Shooters writings so all of that
is true true uh except it's spelled
louder with a u i don't know if
you
yeah loader it's not a typo somewhere in
an article it's in the Chiron way he the
way he just said that though you've been
accused of these things homophobia ET
and then it said and he stands by these
beliefs yeah exactly the just the way
they they insinuate you cannot Escape
that but tell me do me a favor I've been
accused but you didn't accuse me I will
accuse you of being a a partisan hack
who just isn't honest about it well
people tell you yes I am biased I am I
comment below have you ever heard me say
that I am an
unbiased journalist ever have you ever
heard how now on the flip side how many
times give or take have you heard me say
I am biased of course that doesn't
change the fact that I'm seeking the
truth and we make the references
available my problem is with people who
lie about it yeah exactly I don't care
if Jesus Christ had presented these
documents I wouldn't be looking at him
and saying well I have a problem with
you or I like you so they must be true I
would be looking at the documents and
seeing what the documents said you guys
are missing the vote and it's so obvious
that there is no good reason for you
doing that you're not attacking our
commentary on these documents you're
attacking the very fact that we released
them the person trying to paint us like
which you wanted to do exactly but how
does let's let's assume that you were
not only accused of all those things but
guilty of all those things does it
change a single word on the page I'm
probably guilty of at least one well I'm
just
saying homophobic I don't know we'll see
you're afraid of homophobes guess what
if it's if it's Charles Manson who
happened to like find him Mano like all
right he's like I found the manifesto
for my cellmate you like okay well I
don't think the schas on the for's a
good look but he seemed to check out
okay still be admissible evence it's so
irrelevant and it's so obvious what
they're trying to do here and I don't
know if it's them being pissed off or
trying to run cover for maybe these
things should never just have seen the
light of day because we don't like what
well local news is an illusion just to
be clear anyone who thinks ah the Golden
Age of Journalism there was no golden
age of Journalism Walter kronite was was
a completely biased teack and in local
news doesn't exist it's run by basically
three companies just to be clear so
here's how uh they covered the rest or I
guess a a portion of this um of the
interview and how they chose to present
it between the 5 and 6:00 broadcast
local news as we said Crowder has an
agenda and I asked what the agenda was
for his Source in releasing three pages
of
writings and a lot of people thought
that it was necessary for uh this to be
out there and there are people involved
with the Nashville PD who also believe
that uh things haven't been necessarily
uh transparent we want that so we can
examine it for context we can use
experts to evaluate this you have only
released three pages and I'm wondering
if you think that's irresponsible I
sincerely don't believe for a second and
I don't think that you do that any of
this would have ever been released if
not for what took place today I hope if
they have more and there's more context
great I want to our job here is is done
so let me tell you something that wasn't
how I answered that question by way it
still kind of stands but I didn't answer
it in that sequence and this is another
trick that they pull that's not how the
guy looked when I spoke very difference
with him can can you get can you guys
can you guys get me some of the lighting
difference oh wow his hair's on the
other and by the way can you guys get me
some of that lighting they made the they
made this hack look like David Morris
the GU job yeah they did a very good job
and I know and look and and it's and
it's silly you know because he's
obviously um hiding what he actually
looks like there's a reason he's local
but the dishonesty there is when you
record an interview and then they go out
they go back afterward and re-record
their questions now I won't say that in
this case he misrepresented his
questions but they will do that you know
a lot of the times people would ask why
would these on The Daily Show why would
they answer those absurd questions
because they didn't right those
questions were never asked and then
afterwards they filmed themselves asking
those questions but here's something
they can do for example when I'm doing
interview number 3 four five or you're
doing that uh in a given day word
whiskers he can out his word whiskers
maybe he mispronounces something maybe
one of his sources is not correct maybe
he was caught flat footed and I asked
him a question Point Blank and there was
a very long pause because he didn't know
how to answer because he's not equipped
for it all of those things can be edited
out if not completely wiped from the
record to change the dynamic of the
interview that you see so here is how I
fully addressed the question and again
the full video with full context is now
available on X here's how I addressed it
in its full context uh when he asked me
about just releasing three pages as
journalists we want the entire Manifesto
released we want that so we can examine
it for context we can use experts to
evaluate this you have only released
three pages and I'm wondering if you
think that's
irresponsible why would that be
irresponsible there isn't a context to
it what I think is irresponsible is how
long has it been since this
shooting uh roughly at what eight to
nine months yeah some somewhere between
yeah I think it's late seven call it 8
months okay who's been involved in this
investigation I mean not only the PD
right but you have the FBI involved
these people saying that it's you know
this information should not get out
there they want this suppressed uh but
they haven't been able to name any other
people of Interest with their
investigation and the American public
has seen
nothing we know more about the Christ
Church shooting which by the way if you
look at that Manifesto it was trolling
in this case this is authentic this is
someone who was deranged this is someone
who was steeped their entire life it's
seems uh in the modern Progressive
ideology you know you don't use the term
White Privilege um unironically before
you commit a mass shooting
[Music]
crackers sincerely don't believe for a
second and I don't think that you do
that any of this would have ever been
released if not for what took place
today and by the way you can comment
below i w 100 100% stand behind that
if if we didn't do what we had done
yesterday you'd still know nothing and I
don't believe you would ever have had
anything I
[Music]
don't
was done at the very least now people
know they were sold a false bill of
goods or at Le at least they know the
truth was hidden from them yeah I just
want to be clear I I absolutely we would
not be having this conversation it would
still be about victimizing lgbtq plus
people when it was just some person who
was mentally deranged and keep in mind
again remember those pronouns we
discussed earlier they wanted to honor
them because they were more concerned
about avoiding those landmines when this
is before the bodies had even assumed
room temperature well now when they know
that this person obviously um was
motivated by modern Progressive ideology
they want to distance themselves like no
no no no no no this is just a crazy
person so the pronouns aren't all that
important right here you go we have
heard repeatedly that this was person
that was so mentally ill that there may
no be there may not be any understanding
of why she did what she did because she
was so mentally ill but I don't have the
entire conf I don't have the entire all
of her writing I don't you say she why
do you say
she well I will say she because I have
interviewed um her attorney for the F
family and the family refers to her as
she and although she identified as
transgender um she's not here to
basically describe for herself um what
she preferred to be so at this point I
am going with what the family and how
they described her um but you know we're
also but why let me ask this why are we
taking the word for it right because
this person was I believe 28 years old
right Aiden is how they find the Aiden
is how they last referred to themselves
right they were becoming a a male when
they committed this shooting they
identified as a male this family that's
right has not seen the man handed it
over to the authorities has not seen
according to the family they have not
seen the Manifest so when when the
shooting happened right it was a game of
of of walking backwards with landmines
where people were being condemned for
using the wrong pronouns now I'm not
pulling a gotcha with
you
[Music]
oh
p
[Music]
oh
p
[Music]
about this on the news on all the
platforms just like the other cases and
you know what they did they said oh
anti-black racism that's the only kind
of racism I guess racism against black
people is on the rise and we need task
forces and we need to kind of send these
memos out to all of the doj people that
we can possibly find to say hey be on
the lookout for white supremacy this
thing is on the r
they took STS now I disagree with what
they were doing don't get meong but they
took proactive steps because it was
actionable information that's the same
thing
[Music]
here everybody wants to remain silent
it's because they didn't get their first
gu and by the way they didn't get their
first the full interview was up on X and
of course take this opportunity
regardless of whether you know you you
join mug club or not just the free
program every day in the content Rumble
X Spotify Apple wherever you listen to
podcasts you know we still do an hour
plus uh for free every single day and of
course there are other shows that go for
free Nick depalo portion is free so just
don't let them pinch the valve if you're
still uh you know um YouTube dependent
okay so this this kind of brings us to
uh the next portion so you have them big
Tech okay throttled banned outright from
all of the platforms that exist with the
exception of X and Rumble and by the way
thank you Rumble yeah couldn't be more
happy with the brass set of pendulus
balls that they
have that's what I have I just have the
CEO of Rumble Chris pavloski I have them
stand on my desk so it does
the is that a soothing
s I'm stressed I need the take those are
different things that's just C them cup
them don't do that c them so here's the
man uh Brent Leatherwood now uh from
what I understand this person uh is the
parent of someone who was there at at
covenant or of a student at Covenant
School uh who was not uh I don't believe
shot or killed that day but I can only
obviously heart goes out to someone who
was involved with that would have to be
a horrible experience I can't even
imagine so this person though is now
going out and claiming to represent the
parents the families now there' be no
way to verify it you know who could
verify it journalists but they choose
not to certainly not the New York Times
so this person who is now claiming to be
the representative of the families said
that the release of the manifesto was
going to was opening Old Wounds this is
the new line of attack
unimaginable Terror that's how Brent
Leatherwood describes the day in March
when a shooter entered the Covenant
School killing three kids and three
staff members his three kids survived
the shooting but his heart aches even
more after conservative talk show hosts
leaked images of the shooters writings
so
now the
community a
school families who have already
suffered so
much were left yet
again to deal with this
Terror I don't agree with that I just
don't so well you know what I understand
but let's let's go through some claims
and truth I'm not I'm not I'm not saying
that he doesn't have a right to be very
emotional about this that this is really
delicate stuff but you you you have
video of this woman readily available
anytime you want shooting this school up
shooting through breaking that one I
[Music]
don't
p
[Music]
you
no
[Music]
p
e
[Music]
oh
protect our sources with topics that are
relevant here as it relates to their
security that's why you can send your
tips to lwc tips at protonmail.com a lot
of them have come in some of the leads
we are chasing down right now the hair
in the back of your neck will stand up
and you know what else there are a lot
of people out there who they ask you to
send in tips and I know you've probably
experienced this some folks they roll
over and they give up they give up your
name
that will not happen here no 100% and
look do it now like I don't want these
guys to have to relive this anymore than
is absolutely necessary and forced on
them by the police by the way they
wouldn't have to be reliving this if the
police had just released this Manifesto
to us when all of this was happening so
that we could have an understanding of
it we could move on we could be done
with this I want to be done I want the
entire Manifesto out there I want it out
there now I want all of the relevant
information to be released now so that
we can take action to prevent this from
happening in the future and I want these
people to be able to go on and live
their lives and not have to relive this
tragedy again but we don't have that
right now what we have is people getting
in the way of that and criticizing
anybody who does try to get all of that
information out to the public get out of
the way guys we have to do this we can
handle the truth we just need it I
believe it's the National Association of
police that the public had a right to
know and by the way this is largely a
union supportive organization it's not
like they're on our side we're not the
only ones by the way who who who who
were looking for this we're the only
ones who actually got it because we had
someone who felt comfortable sending it
to us do we have that we have the light
of day Clip yeah so keep in mind claim
let's bring up claim again here uh uh
tool man just claim where this you know
could affect law enforcement's ability
to run an ongoing investigation the
truth they already determined that there
shouldn't be an investigation so that
being said do you believe in the
authenticity of the pages in those
photos with the knowledge you have so in
my mind whether it is images or whether
it's something that is inspired by what
the shooter thought wrote or did that
day all of it is reprehensible and none
of it should see the light of day ah
well there you go it's not his choice
hey can I investigate that well I would
let you but it can't see the light of
day he's not that Authority he doesn't
have that Authority it just has to be in
that box well yeah because if it goes
out of the box you know light of day so
um it stays
there he also had a message by the way
for us and you you right now watching
and listening he had a challenge for us
the online shock
jock Who aired these
images I would challenge
him and anyone who amplifies them
online just be a human okay first off
that's not really a
challenge a little broad yeah uh also to
anyone who has Amplified
[Music]
it go you mean everybody and Elon
Musk by the way right now we do have
some breaking news is this an article
hold on one thing really quickly just
one thing before you go to that and by
the way there was a poll that was
conducted I don't know if it was this
this one of these stations that was
running it can someone let me know where
that who conducted this poll and uhv it
was Fox Nashville okay and they covered
this so Fox Nashville conducted a poll
87% of people who answered thought that
the manifesto should have been released
at the start of the investigation
87% they want you to believe that the
87% of you actually only make up some
small 10 5% of the population don't let
them Gaslight you yeah Gerald it looks
like two police officers have been fired
uh right now over this so I I'm I'm not
sure like that's a little long for me to
go through all of
it so yeah that's a lot so guys give me
give me a condensed version of that I
need to understand the the facts are two
police officers being fired today from
this let me see that
guys all right you just got word two
officers are due to be fired over the
release of this Pages allegedly the
documents were sold by one of oh boy I
don't uh I don't know that is true what
what it says they're due to be fired
over this so they haven't been
officially fired what I do find funny
there is like I wanted to wait to verify
the authenticity because I didn't feel
like it represented it accurately but
I'm going to release that two people are
due to likely be fired at some point
somebody sold the documents this is the
problem oh they're trying to say someone
sold the documents pull that back up
that's what it pull it back up I need
someone guys I can't look because I'm
fired over the release of the pages
allegedly the documents were sold by one
of the officers okay so here's what I
can say I don't know where C Candace is
getting this information um no one sold
us anything no we do not purchase
anything and I I would tend to say that
so if they are if they are firing two
current police officers for selling
documents they're screwing up and
they're going to be opening themselves
up to liability but hey you know what we
called ourselves to the mat yesterday
and said these are our predictions
Candace now obviously I do appreciate
her staking her reputation on the line
and uh if it turns out that two police
officers are fired because they sold
these pages to someone else I can tell
you that we never purched purchased
anything then my hats off to her for
staking because because her reputation
will be sted on that yeah that's a bold
claim yeah so hopefully more more inform
again this is why more information needs
to come out about all of this we need to
get all this thing out of the public and
be done with it and move on with
everybody's lives but I don't know if
anybody's going to be fired or not we'll
keep our eye out yes we will keep oure
they want this to exist entirely in
darkness and remember as we've told you
and we've we've run the AB testing
Darkness not our friend
here
[Music]
[Applause]
all right and so finally and you know
what I meant to write a recap down here
at the end just as far as big Tech all
that so maybe I can kind of help get
this in the map just so just so we recap
everything because I know that there's
it's like drinking from a fire hose all
the references are available at lwith
cr.com to people watching this brings us
finally to hey government the mayor of
Nashville Freddy oconnell guess his
political
persuasion he now announced that the so
so just to again th banned by the two
biggest companies that have ever existed
as far as you know media in in modern
history okay banned by them uh and then
threatened of course by local media so
we have big Tech then we have media all
over the place New York Times National
media saying uh this is wrong we don't
we don't think this is true then okay we
verify the authenticity but this
shouldn't have happened anyway and now
we actually have members of
government attacking the people
attacking the messenger for a leak that
was put in our lap so the Nashville
mayor Freddy oconnell announced that the
city will be launching an investigation
into the leak he said I am deeply
concerned with the safety security and
well-being of the Covenant families and
all Nash villians who are grieving how
does this make them less safe what makes
people less safe is if you understand a
motive and a Target and certainly if you
are not conducting an investigation and
asking everyone involved with this
person and I would start with their
agenda that we posted then you don't
know if it could have been prevented or
have at least some idea as to how you
might prevent the next one and the
police stated this regarding to the
authenticity of the images saying that
the photographs are not mnpd crime scene
images well no of course nobody
ever said that they were a notebook
we're not saying you sent them to us
from your from behind the caution tape
we got the images this is them TR no one
is refuting the authenticity they're
just saying well it didn't come from our
department no one's claiming that you
did I love that that's the response and
just remember this was when these were
yet to be confirmed and I'm like huh
yeah do you typically investigate things
that are not authentic I think you just
confirmed it to the entire world that
these are authentic images this was
around noon yesterday or so well and by
the way and he was very nice the person
who I spoke with we did we did try to
call to get an official response from
the Metro Nashville Police dep
Department good afternoon Chief Drake's
office this is James speaking how may I
help you hi James this is Steven Crowder
calling is a chief Drake in please he's
not available at this time well this is
just regarding a story that uh your
department commented on uh as it relates
to the you know the Nashville Shooters
Manifesto that was released today so
again that's uh Steven Crowder at the
number that you have hold on one second
let me uh let me transfer you over
public affairs office Noel speaking hi
Noel how are you today doing all right
you I'm doing all right thanks sorry I
was just transferred to you from uh
James was looking for uh Chief Drake
regarding the uh the Nashville uh
Manifesto that was released today your
department uh issued a comment uh on it
and uh I'm step Crowder I'm the person
whose team broke
it oh uh our department has not issued
one yet I know that we're working on a
statement but like the department here
has not hold on one second okay thank
you Metro Nashville Police Department is
looking to recruit the next class of
officers that's joined mnp
d.com hello
hello
hey
hi this is Don Aaron oh hey Don Aaron
how are you today I'm good I was just
transferred from James to Noel and I was
just put on hold and uh okay here you
are so I'm guessing no one's filled you
in no they just said uh that you were
holding oh okay Don well I'm I'm sorry I
can see how wires get crossed okay I I'm
I have not heard from the Star today and
I don't know if any of my team has heard
from the Star well April on on my team
did okay uh
uh and I I think that was uh essentially
a phone call saying that they had talked
to somebody at the general
assembly uh and and that was it and just
to be clear uh don seemed like a very
very nice guy this is not at all to say
that this is to say that there might be
people interacting with other Journal uh
journalistic Outlets unbeknownst to him
they they don't know what's going on in
their own Department he seemed like a
really nice guy he was very Cooperative
I just I don't want you to think oh this
guy no problem there well this is
because there was an article that we
quoted yesterday where the chief said he
doesn't know anything about that and and
or basically the spokesperson for the
for MPD said that and we were trying to
get some clarification on that right so
that was the whole setup so the only
statement now that I guess is official
but I don't believe it's coming from
someone who would be in charge of of
issuing a statement like Don is that the
photographs are not mnpd crime scene
images well thanks for the help and it
seems that uh these people have already
made their minds up again they made
their minds up that you would never see
this you would never see the truth okay
now that the truth has come out they
have made up their minds um that they're
not going to address it they're going to
attack the messenger now keep in mind
we're talking about this Nashville mayor
if you you want to know as we LED
Today's Show with why would he not want
you to know the truth why would he not
want you to know what is in this
Manifesto why would he not want you to
know the motive this is what that mayor
said the day after the shooting is there
any hope that we will get this Manifesto
because I think the public deserves
answers on the why here I don't know I
think that's going to be a choice that's
made by police here and potentially
other law enforcement and authorities
that involved sure we want to understand
the motive but I think this is also an
opportunity to look forward to policy
and I'm probably as an individual ready
to talk more about how we prevent these
kinds of tragedies including what the
president was talking about yesterday
with regard to renewing the assault
weapons bang no sure I would like to
know the motive but I'm more interested
in policy of prevention okay okay
wouldn't the motive determine the policy
of prevention right in other words if
the motive would be I just want to have
as many guns and shoot as many people as
possible cuz I like guns okay your
policy solution would be gun control if
the motive is I want to kill white
people because of their white privilege
and
crackers and heteronormative patriarchy
communities if that is the motive you
might go oh wait a second this is being
taught everywhere in public schools as a
matter of fact I've championed this so
maybe let's put the reins on that a
little bit so that we can Implement
policy based on the motive that we know
and the targeting that we know to try
and prevent it in the future sure I
guess we want motive but but I'm more
interested in policy let me guess gun
control nailed it absolutely yeah but
there's also something about what you
just said if that is a person fighting
against you know the patriarchy and the
entire structure that's a victim that's
a revolutionary with within the
progressive mind there is something
virtuous about a victim even when they
pick up a gun and kill children as you
saw in that demonstration where they
were holding up seven there were seven
Vic and there's a whole narrative now
going on where when a
comes in and has killed people or
committed a crime they are being
characterized as victims as well because
this is what Society I.E America has
done to them and so they also deserve
compassion this is actually what you're
fighting and if you don't fight it now
and speak about it now it gains a
foothold and becomes truth I guess seven
victims is quicker to say than six
victim six victims and one act of
Justice yeah and you'll start talking
crazy and you'll start saying 2 plus 2
is 16 if you're not careful that's what
happens now gend Spectrum yeah that's
just accepted by the way I wish I could
just edit this show and not do it live
just after the fact because I just I
just had a word whisker and I just get
to edit all of those out so I sound as
though I never misspeak or I never say
uh or I never flub my words when
speaking for two hours that's what they
do that's why a lot of these people now
who have podcasts like all of these
celebrities you go oh they they're
terrible
when they don't have a whole team of
people yeah look when they were doing it
without writers late night oh wow Al not
that interesting no not that interesting
at all yeah so let's recap this what do
we know now okay we hear and I and I I
want to be very clear here this isn't
something that that I did I signed the
fronts of the checks yep and I wanted to
uh I wanted to keep at least
investigative journalism alive that
wasn't simply beholden to a nonprofit
there's not a lot of investigative
journalism out there of course you have
people like James O'Keefe doing great
work but he can't do all of it there
needs to be more than just one person so
I sign the fronts of checks and I work
with this team of people you see me
hosting this show every day this was
their leg work this was their leg work
the Mud Club undercover investigative
unit they did this they've been work and
they've been chasing other leads for a
very long time please comment below hit
the like button show them your love and
support yeah um they've been working
like proud not me of them they broke a
story that was buried for 7 months
you've heard of the trail going cold
this was ice
cold then all of us meaning everyone
here and you were immediately censored
by every single big Tech platform that
exists with the exception of X and
Rumble we're called a criminal
organization by YouTube we were attacked
misrepresented by local and National
media even going so far as to edit up
interviews take them out of context to
make it seem as though I said something
different from from what I actually said
you now have those clips and their full
context available we were attacked by a
spokesperson at covenant he contradicted
himself multiple times asked for money
then the mayor of Nashville is launching
an investigation but no
one since noon Central
yesterday has even attempted to refute
the
authenticity of these leaks they're
attacking the
leaks because they're
real and the real leaks are available
because you wanted them and because you
support us in what we do here look we've
had I ask if nothing else hey we told
you we have these pages from the
manifesto we're going to release them
and we did it our word is our bond just
like when we tell you we will protect
our sources with our livelihoods thank
you expect more of this to take place I
just don't think it'll be all that
different New York Times Washington Post
it's the same old crap and expect them
to do it to you in your life no matter
what no matter what situation it may be
it could be a small instance of of Truth
needing to be told in your office but HR
doesn't want to deal with it it could be
something on your own social media page
it could be something in your department
expect this to happen when you speak
truth it will be about attacking the
messenger if it is an opinion that has
been de deemed impermissible and all of
this you need to just like Co just like
the elections
um right after the
shooting it was we have no
idea have no idea the
motive then they switched to it's just a
crazy person tried to get the gender
pronouns right we really don't know oh
wa we're launching an investigation
which they were not it was just like Co
it was an agreed upon
lie it was an agreed upon
lie and if one person says I don't agree
with that lie I will not go along with
that lie
they will destroy you and anyone around
you so we appreciate it if you think
we've done some handywork you can
consider joining M Club we're going to
continue taking your chats if not Rumble
Spotify where wherever you want to watch
it for free and at some point we ask
that you support us you can click the
button right there to join mug club uh
and join in on the chat right now Brian
K's going to be at good nights is it
North Carolina South Carolina North
Carolina North Carolina Calgary after
that on the 9th 10th 11th brian.com we
very much appreciate you and I think
there will be some developments and we
may have to do some emergency streams of
course tomorrow the debate stream at
night so no stream in the morning live
drinking game rules neck depalo is going
to be it's going to be a lot lighter I
mean aside from you know Chris
Christie's portion of the stage will
have to be it'll have to be reinforced
but outside of that we're all children
thank you Rumble YouTube if we're still
there piss
off
[Applause]
[Music]
what